you may have recognized a few faces on
the hit series atlanta wondering where
you know them from or what other popular
shows and films they've starred in one
actor was actually in a recent star wars
production keep watching to find out who
and so much more
matthew barnes shows up in the second
season of atlanta as lucas the manager
of a rapper named clark county he and
earn have known each other for some time
but there doesn't seem to be much of a
friendship between them in fact lucas
doesn't hesitate to try and woo paper
boi away from him thankfully this
doesn't happen lucas gets taken away by
the tsa after clark county has him take
the fall for a firearms offense barnes
decided to commit to acting after
getting a bachelor's degree from auburn
university where he studied radio
television and film before he landed the
role of lucas he appeared in an episode
of the vampire diaries as jay he played
a member of the mystic falls community
protection squad who died via a stake to
the neck in 2017 he joined the cast of
the tyler perry series the haves and the
have-nots as officer allen you may also
recognize him as agent wallace from the
series strange angel or as peter crane
from the 2021 film queen bees
like many characters in atlanta former
teacher vanessa van keefer is at a
crossroads her relationship status with
earn is constantly in question she wants
to make it work but knows it probably
never will and she struggled to find the
right path for herself since losing her
teaching job this complex character is
played to perfection by zazie beets who
received an emmy nomination for a
performance in 2018. since her first
acting credit in 2013 beats has been
working like crazy in 2016 she appeared
as ally in the mini-series margot vs
willie she began playing van on atlanta
the same year and she also debuted as
noel in the netflix series easy two
years later she played the lucky mutant
domino in deadpool 2 one of the only
members of x-force to survive their
parachute mission she starred in another
r-rated comic book film in 2019
appearing as sophie the object of
arthurflex romantic delusions in joker
she continues to work steadily and shows
no signs of slowing down in the pilot
episode of atlanta earn needs to
convince his cousin al that he can be
his manager to do this he decides to try
and get his single played on a local
radio station he has a connection named
dave played by griffin freeman who
considers earn a friend but isn't
willing to help him out earn goes over
his head to get the track played but
they seem to be on friendly terms when
he pops back up in season two one of
griffin's earliest and most recognizable
roles was margo's unfaithful boyfriend
jace in the 2015 film paper towns based
on the novel by john green he went on to
make appearances in the television shows
ray donovan ncis los angeles and the
goldbergs fans of the walking dead will
no doubt recognize him as mark a member
of the savers who got punished by negan
for sleeping with amber his
ex-girlfriend amber ended her
relationship with mark to become one of
negan's wives giving her access to
medication for her sick mother
there's plenty other gals who would love
to take your place and there's a few job
openings that i can think of
atlanta season three opens with a
perfect reminder of how surreal dark and
hilarious the show can be with a
standalone episode that focuses on an
entirely new character aquarius is a kid
just trying to get by in school but
nobody wants to give him a genuine
chance his mother and grandfather are
fed up with him and his foster mothers
are terrifying people who should have
never been allowed to watch over
children fronting the season premiere is
a lot of pressure to put on a young
man's shoulders but christopher farrar
never plays a weak note he commands our
attention and empathy from start to
finish which is no surprise given the
experience he's already had in the
entertainment business in just seven
years the young actor has made
appearances in highly respected shows
like jane the virgin all-american veep
and young sheldon in 2020 he played
augie roberts in several episodes of the
medical drama chicago met when alfred
miles isn't playing video games or
selling marijuana he's performing under
the name paperboy he decides to take his
rap career seriously when his eponymous
song gets some attention but he soon
discovers that the music business isn't
all it's cracked up to be al struggles
to get paid what he deserves without
compromising his pride or diluting his
image he is played by brian tyree henry
who is emmy nominated for his
performance in the series like many
others his career began with a role in
the long-running police procedural law
and order not long after this he had a
multi-episode run as winston on hbo's
boardwalk empire and he played travis
brown in vice principles another hbo
show in 2018 he played fanny's friend
daniel in the romantic drama if beale
street could talk based on the james
baldwin novel of the same name that same
year he was part of the star-studded
cast of the steve mcqueen film widows he
has also worked on blockbuster flicks
like joker godzilla vs khan and the 2021
marvel studios epic eternals he
co-starred as fastos a member of the
titular group the holy trinity at the
center of atlanta consists of earn al
and a fascinating character named darius
while many people in al's orbit are
concerned with how they appear darius
doesn't mind what people think of him
full of dubious factoids and drawn to
the esoteric darius is one of those
people you can never quite figure out
but you're always glad he's around
your simulation
he's played by lakeith stanfield an
actor who can stand out in a role while
disappearing into it at the same time
you might recognize him when he shows up
but you quickly accept him as the
character allowing any pre-existing
expectations to fall away early in his
career stanfill portrayed civil rights
activist jimmy lee jackson in the 2014
eva duvernay film selma the following
year he was snoop dogg in the nwa biopic
straight out of compton he had a
memorable role in jordan pale's get out
playing andre the character who first
confirmed chris's suspicions that
something was very wrong at his
girlfriend's childhood home
get out
yo
in 2018 he starred as telemarketer
cassius green in the boots riley film
sorry to bother you and in 2021 he
reunited with his get out co-star daniel
kaluuya for judas and the black messiah
he was nominated for an oscar for his
turn as real-life fbi informant bill
o'neil in the film at first raleigh marx
portrayed by isaiah whitlock jr doesn't
really have much time for his son earned
when earned stops by the house in the
pilot episode he refuses to let him in
because he knows he's going to ask for
money he is clearly disappointed in his
son's decision to leave princeton but he
knows not to push him on the subject
when al asks him if he can trust earn to
be his manager raleigh admits he doesn't
blame his nephew for being cautious
however he assures him that when his son
really wants to do something he gets it
done isaiah whitlock jr is one of those
actors that seems to show up everywhere
he has over 120 credits to his name he's
appeared in everything from shows like
law and order and as the world turns to
movies like gremlins 2 the new batch and
goodfellas he's known for his
collaborations with spike lee having
plied his trade in 25th hour black
klansmen and the five bloods fans of
hbo's the wire will no doubt recognize
him as clay davis maryland's corrupt
senator we meet earn's mother in the
pilot episode of atlanta but it's not
until the season 2 episode fubu that we
get a sense of who she is like any
mother mrs banks only wants what's best
for her son this means not sugar coating
things for him and giving life lessons
like the importance of hard work always
making a good first impression and
sticking by your family she is played by
myra lucretia taylor who has been active
in hollywood since the 1990s taylor has
made several tv appearances on shows
like girls elementary madame secretary
the unbreakable kimmy schmidt and
hunters in terms of future films she's
known for sydney lumets before the devil
knows you're dead and the hit rom-com
the big sick in which she plays nurse
judy while all of this was happening she
also worked extensively in the theater
even spending a lot of time on broadway
rj walker joined the cast of atlanta in
its second season playing the rapper
clark county he's initially friendly
without but there is something very
sinister bubbling below the surface
while al is concerned with making it as
an artist without compromising a sense
of normalcy clark county is fine with
sacrificing the people closest to him to
achieve his goals walker studied drama
and improv before landing his first tv
role he guest starred on major crimes
and appeared in an episode of castle at
the beginning of his career he went on
to secure roles in toulava to lantela
switched at birth and the amy poehler
film wine country in 2019 he began
playing david wright in the bet series
boomerang a sequel to the eddie murphy
film of the same name
donald glover is probably the most
widely recognizable atlanta actor he
stars as earnest earned marks an
intelligent and creative guy with
something to prove earn left college
before the start of the series and has
been trying to find his place in the
world ever since although he truly
believes he has what it takes to manage
his cousin al's rap career his
inexperience leads to continuous
missteps and failures not only is glover
the primary protagonist of atlanta but
he is also the show's creator in
addition to frequently pinning and
directing episodes glover is a
multi-hyphenate who has been blazing his
own unique trail in film television and
music for years and early success for
him was the role of troy barnes he
played a former high school football
player who buckled under the pressure of
being a star athlete and wound up
attending greendale community college
rather than a major university and
community he had a small role on 30 rock
a show he also wrote for he was also
impressive as the young lando calrissian
in the underrated 2018 film solo a star
wars story if you're not familiar with
any of his other acting work you may
know him better as rap artist childish
gambino
arguably the most recognizable atlanta
cast member after donald glover cat
williams appeared as earn's uncle willy
in the season two opener alligator man
just as clark county is a reflection of
what al could be if he allowed himself
to be corrupted by the music business
willie symbolizes what could happen to
earn if he doesn't get his act together
you scared
most people know williams for his
prolific career as a stand-up comedian
though he's also been acting since 2002
he got the ball rolling with a guest
appearance on the crime drama nypd blue
and made his movie debut that same year
appearing in the third installment of
the friday franchise friday after next
other notable film credits include
norbit epic movie first sunday and for
the love of money in 2021 he starred
opposite mike epps in the house next
door playing a vampire pimp this sequel
to the 2016 comedy meet the blacks was
arguably one of the worst movies of 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one